[Musique]
et là on voulait pas pour les lunettes
de soleil un l'âge de soleil en patron
je viens de passer vingt minutes à faire
la miniature de la vidéo je n'en peux
plus j'ai les yeux qui vont complètement
explosé à cause de la lumière mais je
suis très heureux parce que c'est la
première fois que je n'ai testé une
tesla la toute première fois c'est le
modèle y le pas là le modèle y est sujet
c'est un suv c'est une belle voiture je
suis déjà monté dans une tesla mais j'en
ai jamais conduit c'est donc ma première
expérience avec une voiture c'était ça
et je vais vous donner mon retour non
pas sur l'empattement non pas sur le
châssis n'ont pas sorti et ça je vous
parlais de mon expérience personnelle
bien évidemment sur tout ce qui va être
connectivité embarquée sur les ressentis
en termes de conduite sur ce véhicule
[Musique]
est ce qu'elle n'a pas la classe quand
même on a l'impression d'être sur une
modèle 3 quand on la regarde comme ça
pourtant c'est un poil plus grands moi
ce que je vais adorer 6 et les jantes
alors là ils sont un peu creux 2-1
forcément jeu sur les bouts de chemin
c'est une version avec les jantes en 20
pouces des poignets ne trouve pas
extrêmement pratique parce que lorsque
vous avez un peu les mains prises bah
c'est pas évident vous appuyez avec le
pouce faute s'ils réclament un autant
c'est très profilé autant ce n'est pas
le système le plus pratique si vous avez
des choses dans les mains vous poussez
up ya plus rien à tirer vous l'attraper
de côté bon là ça se fait mais c'est pas
ce système le plus évident ce qui est
sympa sur ce modèle est bien c'est que
vous avez une vitre à l'arrière qui est
teinté parce que en fait vous n'avez pas
de 2,2 fois qu'on la passe à deux portes
à hayon vous avez rien sur le dessus ce
qui fait que tout est potentiellement
visible ici à travers la vitre mais ça
ne pose absolument pas problème parce
qu'on y voit absolument rien et vous
l'avez vu à l'intérieur on a beaucoup de
place mais si vous manquez encore un peu
de place va vous en avez encore un peu
plus vous venez tirer sap afin grands
rangements alors là vous pouvez poser
vos valises kabyle des câbles et
compagnie si vous le souhaitez et si
vous manquez encore un peu de place mais
vous en avez encore un petit peu ici
pouvait encore angers un peu là si vous
manque encore un peu de place ben vous
avez un peu de place ici pour me ranger
ben je sais pas quoi des petits bouts de
trucs d'un côté et également de l'autre
en un grand toit panoramique alors ça
c'est vachement mais parce qu'en fait
vous avez de la place on risque pas de
se cogner ça apporte de la lumière et
pour autant on voit peu le ciel bleu
mais c'est pas une vie de transparents
comme celle que je peux avoir sur les
côtés donc là c'est pareil je veux payer
l'apéro mais passagers trouvent que les
finitions sont très sympas alors il ya
le côté bois je sais pas si vous aimez
le bois clair mais assez élégant vous
avez un petit côté un peu feutrine sur
le côté qui est sympa leveaux en trait
épuré très simple très efficaces ils
n'étaient cela la grande tablette 15
pouces c'est pareil ça marche très très
bien avec une expérience logiciel qui
est absolument dingue estime c'est la
meilleure expérience que j'ai pu tester
aujourd'hui sur n'importe quelle voiture
il faut fatalement le temps de
l'apprivoiser mais c'est vraiment super
super bien il ya des rangements de tous
les côtés peut il rentrer ma main est
allé jusque là au bout je touche pas le
bund deux petits porte gobelets ici de
la même manière ici regardez l'âge et
des grands grands rangements est ce que
je vous ai pas montrer c'est qu'ici et
bien j'ai dû 12 volts est ici là j'ai
deux prises en usb c est juste à l'avant
ici en fait ces deux pattes de
rechargement sans fil et je veux me
poser mon iphone 13 promax donc il ya
vraiment ce qu'il faut en terme de
taille de la même manière beaucoup de
place pour les jambes du passager
dérangement sur le côté mais vous avez
également un coffre à l'avant alors bon
c'est pas le plus grand du monde vous
peut quand même y mettre une valise
[Musique]
qui m'a surpris quand je me suis assis
c'est que je trouve que le siège est un
petit peu bac et au niveau des fesses ça
vient de nous lever un peu le popotin
mais bon globalement sensation a disparu
très très vite ici on nous annonce qu'on
est sur du cuir vegan le cuir degen ça
n'existe pas qu'est ce que ce soit du
cuir soit pas du cuir donc c'est une
matière synthétique mais que je trouve
assez sympa d'aller en punition noir
enfin c'est un gris en fait mais vous
pouvez également la voir en finition
blanc avec en plus un revêtement anti
tache pour venir nettoyer facilement
mais le blanc ça marche intervenir le
passé un petit coup de chiffon d'être
plus régulièrement et ça bon voilà je
pense que vous avez envie de vous
embêter mais moi j'aime bien comme ça
les jantes noires intérieur noir est la
couleur rouge est magnifique mais s'il
ya vraiment un truc que j'adore c'est
cette tablette si vous connaissez tesla
il ya rien qui va vous surprendre vous
avez tous vos paramètres ici contrôle
rapide l'éclairage de verrouillage vous
faites tous ici en un seul endroit c'est
tellement simple tellement claire
tellement intuitif c'est vraiment
vraiment vraiment bien donc ça c'est les
réglages de du véhicule bon ici j'ai le
gps la musique j'ai de la radio et
compagnie bref pas mal de choses j'ai
spotify j'ai un karaoké donc si je veux
venir chanter je peux venir chanter dans
ma voiture ici j'ai mes caméras avec mes
caméra arrière parce que c'est un peu le
reproche que je peux faire ici c'est
qu'en fait si vous cherchez un regard
dans le rétro la vitre arrière est
tellement petit que vous n'y voyez rien
et pour contrebalancer tu as sabah boom
et des grandes caméra alors là j'ai une
résolution de dingo je vois tout ce qui
se passe à l'arrière après j'ai tout mon
réglage au niveau de mes essuie-glaces
ma consommation d'énergie mon char je
mangeais un navigateur sur le web
également si je veux aller naviguer
lorsque je suis arrêté je peux aller le
faire j'ai du divertissement avec des
jeux et j'ai aussi une option théâtre
principaux me regarder du contenu mais
uniquement lorsque je suis à l'arrêt
netflix youtube switch tesla tutorial et
aux us ils viennent de m'être dit ce
n'est plus donc c'est aussi sympa mais
sièges chauffants oui ou non toute ma
ventilation c'est hyper intuitif un jeu
choisir tout mon réglage de mon flux
d'air directement du bout du doigt c'est
vraiment super la température les sièges
de dégivrage bref l'histoire est
vraiment vraiment cool
et voyez surtout que je reprochais à
différents constructeurs j'ai essayé
sept et elodie q4 itron qui est vraiment
super beau véhicule très belle finition
mais le truc qui manque un peu c'est
toute la connectivité intérieur c'est
pas hyper évident c'est pas hyper fluide
vous avez plein de sous menus bref il ya
des boutons de partout et c'est pas
dingue ici ce qu'ils ont fait tesla ils
ont fait table rase alors c'est pas
nouveau me direz vous tout cela ça fait
un petit moment que ça existe mais c'est
la première fois que je conduis une
tesla donc je reprends un peu les
basiques ils ont fait table rase de tout
et ils ont éliminé toute cette pollution
au niveau des boutons c'est peut-être un
petit peu dur de dire pollution chacun a
sa page chacun sa façon de faire mais
pour moi en tout cas qu'il suit
consommateurs qu'est ce que je vais
aimer suis dans la tête qu'un c'est
clair je vais mais quelque chose de sain
jamais quelque chose d'épuré j'aurais
aimé une solution qui fonctionne je vais
aimer tout ce système aussi de mise à
jour bref tesla un système qui est très
complet très clair là dessus c'est
évident que sur la connectivité sur
l'expérience logiciel ils sont des
centaines de milieu des autres il y en a
une autre que j'ai trouvé intéressante
cc ford avec laure naquit pourquoi parce
que vous avez aussi cette idée de la
tablette alors ya une molette dessus sur
un peu différent mais ça fonctionne et
ce avant tout cas dans le bon sens mais
là ce qu'ils ont ici avec ce modèle
c'est un suv qui malgré tout assez
compact c'est plus de 500 km d'autonomie
c'est un véhicule avec de très belles
finitions vous avez des options d'un
gars ça coûte très très cher bien
évidemment on est chez tesla pouvait
tracts et vous avez de la puissance avec
la performance et vous avez des mises à
jour elle va se mettre à jour
automatiquement et si vous souhaitez
acheter neuf sur plus tard vous pouvez
le faire je vais la trouver un petit peu
dur au niveau des suspensions truc que
je vais vraiment aimé par contre sur ce
véhicule c'est toute l'expérience de
tenue de route vous avez deux batteries
une batterie qui va servir pour l'avant
une batterie qui servira pour l'ariège
vous êtes ici sur une quatre roues
motrices on a donc deux moteurs on a une
tenue de route qui est tellement
confortable avec ce centre de gravité
qui est très bas avec ses deux batteries
après jk pneumatiques michelin nous
assurent elles font vraiment le boulot
et d'acheter demi en conduite ou and
drive c'est à dire qu'en fait la [ __ ]
d'accélération lorsque je l'aimais bien
fresnes et le truc qui est extrêmement
pratique c'est que bon là j'ai vraiment
marqué l'art et hop je freine je
m'arrête là mais sinon lorsque je lève
le pied déjà c'est ça a bien créé
générés au niveau de l'énergie donc ça
ne récupère un petit peu d'autonomie
même si ça va pas me changer la batterie
à fond et évidemment mais malgré tout
c'est quand même plutôt pas mal donc ça
c'est le premier point positif et puis
surtout je lève le pied salut mes fans
arrière ça freine ça m'évite en plus
devenir usé mes plaquettes et ce qui est
parfait avec ses deux moteurs déjà que
ça vous donne un couple de dengue et 3
que vous aller de 0 à 100 quelque chose
comme 5 secondes un truc est absolument
démentielle regardez l'accélération que
ça quand j'appuie sa part mais à une
vitesse pouvait prendre les petites
routes les petits chemins ça ne bouge
pas alors l'idée s'est pas déroulée
comme un bourrin parce qu'ils vont faire
attention mais en termes de conduite en
termes de plaisir de conduite
c'est dingue dingue dingue complètement
neu
[Musique]
la bonne nouvelle c'est que ce modèle y
est déjà disponible au tarif de 59 1990
euros pourquoi parce qu'ils sont juste
en dessous des 60 mille euros ça c'est
extrêmement mal hein parce qu'en fait
jusqu'à 60 mille euros vous bénéficiez
d'un bonus de 2000 euros ça vous la
tombe à 57 1990 c'est quand même pas
dégueu le modèle y ait des diodes
disponibles ça c'est le modèle grande
autonomie il va y avoir un modèle
performant ce qui va sortir début
d'année prochaine sur ces janvier 2022
qui lui va à tartiner davantage déjà
comme elle est là croyez-moi sa tartine
et parce que oui ça ne s'arrête pas là
vous avez une application chez tesla à
savoir que ici je peux venir verrouiller
déverrouiller mater cela très facilement
directement là où je peux venir régler
ma ventilation actifs désactivé je peux
ouvrir ma prise de recharge bombe à
l'âge peut aussi venir up la refermer
elles se referment ouvrir le capot fermé
le capot j'ai tous les contrôles de mon
véhicule ouvrir le coffre avant fermer
le coffre avant coffre arrière c'est la
même chose les clignotants je peux venir
klaxonner je peux venir démarré je peux
venir ventilé voyez par exemple ici là
haut up là ça m'ouvre un peu les vitres
hop je les ferme donc si j'ai cet animal
de compagnie bien que piloter tout ça à
distance je vois toute ma ventilation
que je peux venir réguler lancé les
sièges chauffants avant arrière je vois
la position où je suis tout de suite
fait toutes les mises à niveau brèche
venir piloter mon véhicule directement
ici avec mon compte mon téléphone c'est
ma clé avec une connexion bluetooth qui
consomme quasiment rien donc c'est
vachement bien et ça c'est super
intéressant parce que imaginons que je
sache que je vais prendre ma voiture
dans une heure parce que commencer à la
mettre en température je peux commencer
à faire ventilé c'est par exemple
suivant la voiture et que quelqu'un veut
venir la prendre et me le demande
gentiment et bien je peux la démarrer en
tout cas la déverrouiller à distance
bref j'ai le contrôle directement avec
mon smartphone quel que soit l'endroit
où je suis et ça s'est super bien là je
vous parle de tesla d'un point de vue
général mais j'imagine que vous êtes
nombreux et nombreuses à savoir tout ce
que je vous dis vous connaissez tesla je
connaissais je n'avais pas testé j'ai
testé ça y est enfin j'espère pouvoir la
prendre en main plus longtemps c'est là
un autre véhicule pour vraiment me
familiariser au fonctionnement
logicielle globale mais comme il est la
chose ça vraiment génial et c'est assez
surprenant que les autres constructeurs
n'ai pas pensé à ça comment est ce qu'on
arrive à allier et bien de la
connectivité une grande table est
intelligente une voiture totalement
intelligente qu'on peut mettre à jour
avec un super suv alors superbe
vachement bien il ya des choses à
corriger doit cette fenêtre arrière j'y
vois absolument rien et que ce vitre
arrière ça me dérange choque pas
l'ancien camp je recule voyez c'est
la main sur le siège je tourne la tête
là je peux pas le faire parce que j'y
vois rien du tout alors effectivement
sur le grand écran sont attablés de 15
pouces je vois mais je suis pas habitué
ça me dérange les rétros se baissent
enfin bref ça c'est pas hyper hyper
confort je trouve les suspensions un
petit peu raide le siège est un peu bas
qu'est mais bon franchement ça va je me
suis habitué je suis vraiment bien
j'aime beaucoup de véhicules il n'est
pas complètement parfait mais il est
vraiment bien et on voit que t'es cela
continue à avancer continue sa
progression avec tous les modèles qui
nous propose là c'est le modèle y il ya
le reste de la gamme qui existe chez
tesla on voit qu'à tout
l'électrification avec plus d'une
centaine de bornes en france sur des
super charger mais vous avez également
des bornes qui sont pas forcément du
super charger mais qui iront très vite
entre de la recharge domestique la
recharge au bureau du super de charger
et toutes les autres banques qui sont
compatibles dans différents magasins
mais qui ne sont pas les super charger
eh bien il ya un réseau qui est là qui
permet aujourd'hui d'avoir une tesla
avoir une tesla si vous avez la
possibilité chez vous de charger ce qui
me paraît très intéressant ou à minima
au bureau sinon c'est un peu compliqué
on en reparlera de tesla je pense que ça
vous botte dites le moi en bas en
commentaire ma part c'est moi j'aime
beaucoup superbe expérience très beau et
suivez belle réussite bravo tesla on
verra ça une prochaine fois d'ici là je
m'en vais j'ai des choses à faire aussi
faire des jeux vidéo donc là je vais en
profiter avant de la rente parce que là
il est quoi il est 14 heures 20 on en
deux heures donc je vais en profiter
[Musique]
le néo romain
roumégas
[Musique]